as I reflect on my own destiny and the
impact that My Heroes Have Had on my
life
I'm reminded
that our heroes are not always perfect
instead they possess a relatability that
makes them touchable
real
when anyone speaks about Allen Iverson
that's exactly what they say
he's real
so a uh I need you to know this
I watched you with all
because I saw a reflection of myself in
you
the way you played the game was exciting
and fearless
it didn't matter who they put in front
of you they wasn't going to stop you
I know I tried
it didn't matter what they said about
you because they couldn't measure the
size of your heart
your authenticity
Unapologetic attitude resonated with me
your Swagger Unique Style for rocking
durags braids the baggy shorts it's an
untucked jerseys the earrings the chains
the throwback jerseys
all combined to create an image that
broke the mold
you challenge conventional norms and
became the poster child for
individuality and self-expression
inspiring countless individuals who
Embrace their own uniqueness
you brought hope to those who grew up
with limited resources
you showed us that success and greatness
were attainable even in the face of
adversity
your struggles made your accomplishments
that much more remarkable
AI you are a living breathe a reminder
that Redemption and growth are possible
you inspired a generation my damn
self-included to believe that coming
from nothing was not a limitation
but motivation
I wore arm sleeve throughout my career
because AI did
I respectfully water number three
throughout my college and NBA career to
represent the love and the respect that
I have for this man
so from the bottom of my heart
you are the culture and we love you and
we thank you Allen Iverson
[Applause]